la baguette emblème de la France
inscrite aujourd'hui au patrimoine
immatériel de l'humanité par l'UNESCO
baguette française rejoint d'autres
traditions culturelles dans le
classement immatériel de l'UNESCO comme
la pizza napolitaine la bière belge ou
déjà le repas gastronomique français qui
y était entré en 2010 ici les agents
sont prêts à faire ce qui n'a encore
jamais été fait couper le courant à des
milliers de français de la région en cas
de fortes tensions sur le réseau
électrique les délaissages comme on dit
se feront depuis ce poste sur ordre du
gestionnaire de transport d'électricité
je voudrais terminer en vous vous en
croustillez cette baguette une citation
de l'abbé Pierre que tous ceux qui ont
faim et du pain et que tous ceux qui ont
du pain et fin de justice et d'amour en
général le matin et puis le soir vers
19h d'éviter de faire tourner le
lave-linge ou de décaler un peu
l'allumage de la plaque de cuisson vous
verrez c'est des mesures extrêmement
simples qui sont en réalité assez peu
contraignantes et qui ont un impact
massif pour éviter qu'on se retrouve
dans des situations même temporaires qui
sont plus délicates écoutez-moi je pense
que c'est de l'infantilisation en fait
monsieur Véran vous le mettez à la santé
il voudrait se le catalogue de ce qu'il
faut faire et pas faire et vous le
mettez maintenant dans d'autres domaines
et il fait exactement la même chose ils
sont pas bêtes les gens c'est pour ça
que je m'engage pour eux qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont vu ils ont vu que le
gouvernement a sorti le fond de
solidarité en un mois qu'il a fallu
l'ajuster on l'ajuster les PGE le
chômage partiel on n'a jamais abandonné
nos entreprises on va pas commencer
aujourd'hui bref surprise une grève des
contrôleurs à la SNCF annoncé pour ce
week-end de vendredi à dimanche le
trafic sera très perturbé sachez-le
Emmanuel Macron poursuit donc en ce
moment à sa visite d'État aux États-Unis
vous voyez cette image au siège de la
NASA à Washington réunion en ce moment
cet américain avait tout prévu un lieu
romantique un bateau lors d'un coucher
de soleil en Floride et deux caméras
pour immortaliser la scène mais en
sortant les crins de sa poche c'est la
bourde heureusement il plonge
instantanément récupère aussitôt la
bague et a pu faire sa demande tremper à
sa petite amie les consommateurs
Américains dépensent 7 dollars pour
avoir une unité de gaz mais les Français
et les Européens l'achètent 37 dollars
plus de 5 fois plus cher les États-Unis
profiteraient-ils abusivement de la
crise énergétique les États-Unis se sont
engagés à livrer à l'Europe 15 milliards
de mètres cubes supplémentaires de gaz
naturel liquéfié un doublement des
exportations en un an pour les
Américains et à l'arrivée des prix
multipliés par 5 mais une énorme marge
qui va dans les poches des industriels
européens ces derniers expliquent que le
prix du marché aujourd'hui en Europe
permet notamment de compenser les pertes
liées à la pandémie voilà pourquoi selon
les experts le voyage du président
français à Washington ne pourra sans
doute pas régler la question l'homme
suit des ouvriers et parvient à se
glisser sans contrôle dans le sein des
saints de la République depuis l'entrée
ouest juste ici l'homme arrive dans la
cour d'honneur fut-elle un chef d'État
en visite officiel et grimpe les marches
du perron jusqu'au vestibule d'honneur
au sens où il est lui voyez ce que je
veux dire et que on ne remplacera
personne qui a fait trois
présidentielles et ce qu'il a fait voilà
donc
remplacer c'est pas la question n'est
pas de le remplacer la question est de
est de savoir éventuellement commencera
la suite il interpelle de lui-même un
huissier du protocole je me suis
présenté bonjour j'aimerais rencontrer
Monsieur le Président c'est pour du
travail dans le management ou en tant
que juriste précise l'intrus
ça ça peut être un sujet mais il n'est
pas d'actualité puisque Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'est pas parti à la retraite
intrusion à la Maison Blanche qui est
quand même censé être le lieu le le plus
surveillé au monde il y en a eu
plusieurs à la Maison Blanche on a vu ce
que ça a donné aussi au Congrès quand il
y a une foule qui arrive c'est la
sécurité à 100% ça n'existe pas il
n'avait pas d'armes et donc les faits
ont été classés le jour même pour
poursuivre il nous porte une entrée à
l'Élysée
[Rires]